[Applause]
i love this time of year because i love
giving gifts
but when i'm getting a present it's all
about the thought that goes into it and
that's why i'm so excited
that we've teamed up with etsy to share
how to make gift giving a little more
personal this year and joining me is
their trend expert
dana isom johnson hi
hello hi dana i'm so thrilled to be
doing this with you
i think we all need a little extra love
this year
so i think that's why it's really more
important than ever
to find the most personalized the most
unique and
special gifts for your family and
friends and when you think about it
so many of us will not be able to be in
person to celebrate
so that's what makes it even more
important to make sure that those loved
ones
feel the love from your gift that they
open even if you're celebrating from
afar
the holidays are all about the kids so
why don't we start there how do we wow
them we both know
kids love to be creative right they love
to make things with their hands
and the other thing they really like to
do is just is to see
items with their name on it so you have
there and i have
something with me too they are custom
personalized uh crayons and here's the
bonus tip for this
you are removing screen time you're
really encouraging kids to be
creative and to spend time making things
with their hands the other item that i
like that's a bit of a throwback
are oversized plush stuffed animals
they're snuggly they're cuddly
and again we're removing some of that
screen time
yes and like you said it's really more
about
the the experience spending time
together and being creative you look
fabulous i love it look at that this
is absolutely one of my favorite items i
also think that not only is this an
interactive toy
but decoratively speaking this could
make a corner of a
of a kid's room um i am so
obsessed with animals as are my kids so
what is going on with pat this is one of
my favorite items i have to say
the one thing that i really want people
to think about
is our fur babies are members of our
families
and you have there with you some
personalized pet portraits that i really
love
uh because it really is cementing their
place in the family tree
and also the other thing i'm really
loving for pets are
personalized velvet collars so luxe
and really perfect for our fur babies
when we go on those fancy walks together
but again
you're pouring love into them because
they're members of our families
this is so chic and so
beautiful okay so apparently this is
trending in the men's department
yes here's why when you think about guys
they never say to themselves hey you
know what i need i need a
personalized portrait or i need that
great decor piece to really set my
living room off
so this is our opportunity to set them
up for a stylish addition to their home
because they're just never going to
think about that i'm a little surprised
these were in the men's department i was
like
men turned on by needlepoint i just did
not
see this happening that's actually me on
the cover of instyle that i shot myself
with my detroit
news t-shirt on and um
i i i can't love this more great so then
the other gift
for guys that i'm loving are cocktail
dice because
this makes more sense
listen look this this is really great
because
so many of us have thought to ourselves
oh you know we've become
amateur mixologists with all our at-home
happy hours
so this is a great way to keep people
creative and inspired what you got drew
what's your fault
honey kumquat gin ginger rosemary
um creme de cassis
cherry bitters and peach i want this
immediately
this sounds so good
that sounds great and again like there's
so many variations that can come out of
this
so again you're keeping the guys
creative you're keeping them thinking
that they're the master mixologist for
happy hour
yeah um and again it's just really great
now
what about the ladies uh so there's two
themes
that i'm really loving that can give
some guidance for gifts the first
is celestial which i'm a huge fan of i
love
anything celestial themed you've got a
really great constellation mug that's
personalized there with you that's great
it has our names in the handles look you
can see
drew and dana okay
[Music]
i love it it's so pretty and um
you can personalize it to any
constellation you want
uh also ice tie dye
oh drew tie dye has been such a
major trend throughout the entire year
it's not slowing down at all yet it's
easy
and just fun and festive and i think
what makes this really great
for a gift is that you you can buy it as
a
diy kit like the one you have there so
it can
really be given to any woman of any age
and they can personalize it
based on their personal style and taste
this
i'm for sure gonna get for my daughter
olive who is a master tiger but i just
i love it and i'm so glad that the trend
of 2020 really was tie-dye
and these are just a few of the great
gift
examples that we have on etsy but you
know we have
millions of handcrafted unique items
that are really perfect for any family
member on your gift list this year i
don't know who i would be without etsy i
am just
and i'm an etsy girl and i love these
gifts
thanks dana so much and make sure you
check out
etsy.com to find the one-of-a-kind gifts
that you can't find
anywhere else
[Music]